américain sous pression à trois mois de
l'élection présidentielle il suggère le
report du scrutin
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue si vous ne
revenez sur rt france la pandémie sera
probablement très longue selon le comité
d'urgence de l'organisation mondiale de
la santé réunie pour la quatrième fois
depuis hier à genève afin de réévaluer
la pandémie en france les indicateurs de
reprise épidémique se sont donc dégradé
durant la dernière semaine de juillet le
nombre de nouveaux cas de contamination
s'accélère celui des foyers identifiés
est également en hausse
des signaux qui révèle que la
circulation du virus s'intensifie sur le
territoire pour y faire face plusieurs
villes impose désormais le port du
masque à l'extérieur comme un biarritz
bayonne saint malo ou encore lille à
compter de lundi il sera obligatoire
dans les lieux publics de 69 communes de
mayenne des nouveaux cas positifs quand
un virus qui seraient pour la plupart à
assen automatique santé publique france
a recensé 51 % de personnes positives
qui ne présentait aucun symptôme
la transmission du virus ne restent pas
moins possible ces malades qui
s'ignorent pourrait également prendre -
précaution une hausse de cas
particulièrement marqué aussi chez les
15-44 ans réaction du professeur jean
paul stahl il est infectiologues au chu
de grenoble alpes
heureusement que ce sont dix jeunes
parce que il est vrai que les formes
graves même si elle existe dans cette
catégorie d'âge sont beaucoup moins
fréquentes
ça c'est un premier point positif le
deuxième point positif c'est que les
patients asymptomatiques sont beaucoup
moins contaminant que les autres ça ne
veut pas dire qu'ils ne sont pas mais
ils le sont moins que ceux qui sont très
symptomatique
donc on peut espérer que pour l'instant
en tout cas on n'assiste pas à
l'explosion qu'on a élu il y à il ya
quelques mois vous rajoutez le meilleur
masque qui est la distanciation
c'est à dire quand on est à distance des
autres en contamine personnes donc les
les trois piliers de la culture que
toute la lutte finalement actuelle c'est
ce sens là et le
éviter de retomber dans le marasme qu'on
a connu il ya quelques temps avec 1 re
confinement généralisez pas ma foi ça
dépend de chacun d'entre nous c'est à
dire du respect de simple bon sens des
mesures même si elles sont
contraignantes parce que il faut
accepter une contrainte relativement aux
drm à temps pour éviter une contrainte
majeure au moins de 7 ans aux doctorants
et selon une étude américaine publiée
cette semaine les très jeunes enfants
pourraient être d'importants propagateur
du virus les chercheurs ont ainsi
observé la présence du co vie 19 en
quantité 10 à 100 fois supérieure aux
autres dans leurs voies respiratoires et
c'était le singe nous en dit plus ces
résultats vont à l'encontre des discours
des autorités sanitaires
selon une étude publiée par la revue
américaine jama paediatrics les enfants
de moins de cinq ans pourraient être
extrêmement contagieux entre le 23 mars
et le 27 avril
une équipe de chercheurs a mené des
tests de dépistage sur 145 patients
ayant développé une forme légère du coc
vite 19
ils ont été répartis en trois groupes
quarante six enfants de moins de 5 ans
51 enfants âgés de 5 à 17 ans et 48
adultes de 18 à 65 ans
chez les moins de 5 ans le taux de
matériel génétique du corona des rues se
retrouver dans leur nez étaient dix à
cent fois supérieur à celui présent dans
le nez des enfants plus âgés et des
adultes
voici ce qu'on a conclu l'équipe notre
étude se limite à la détection de
l'acide nucléique virale plutôt que
celle du virus infectieux bien que des
études pédiatriques sur le sar skov 2 et
mis en évidence une corrélation entre
les taux d'acides nucléiques plus élevés
et la capacité à cultiver le virus
infectieux les habitudes
comportementales des jeunes enfants
ainsi que les locaux exigus dans les
écoles et les garderies pose la question
d'une propagation du sart skov de dans
cette population
à mesure que les contraintes sanitaires
s'assouplissent si les jeunes enfants
s'avère être plus contagieux que prévu
il
serait pas non plus invincible face au
virus pour reprendre le mot du directeur
général de l'om est ce le 30 juillet
dernier durant une conférence de presse
il s'est inquiété de la baisse de
vigilance des jeunes populations face au
virus
les exhortant à prendre davantage de
précautions nous l'avons dit et nous
leur disons les jeunes peuvent être
infectés les jeunes peuvent mourir et
les jeunes peuvent transmettre le virus
il semble que les résurgences des
nouveaux cas dans certains pays sont en
partie dus à des jeunes qui baissent la
garde pendant l'été dans l'hémisphère
nord
les avis divergent sur la façon dont les
jeunes sont touchés par le cos vite 19
et leur potentiel contagiosité
une récente étude en ile-de-france en
date du 4 juin dernier par exemple
démontré que je cite les enfants
semblaient être moins contaminés et
moins contaminant au début de la crise
on a cru comme pour d'autres virus
respiratoires que les enfants jouent un
rôle important dans la propagation de
l'épidémie
ce n'est pas le cas les évidences
s'accumulent
cette maladie touche essentiellement les
adultes les formes les plus graves et
des décès survenant quasi exclusivement
chez des sujets âgés ou présentant des
comorbidités difficile donc de s'y
retrouver face à toutes ses études aux
résultats contradictoires
un peu comme pour le port du masque les
autorités sanitaires peine à parler
d'une seule voix et chef des urgences à
l'hôpital bichat henrique casalino
estime que les conclusions du rapport
sont exagérées sur les routes
c'est un article intéressant mais ce
n'est pas un article qui apporte une
information disruptive il n'a pas fait
la preuve d'une augmentation de la
contamination à partir des enfants de
patients il a simplement apporter un
élément scientifique quelque chose qui
vient alimenter éventuellement un débat
mais qui n'est certainement pas une
preuve ça veut dire simplement qu'il y a
un peu plus
virus au niveau de la gorge des enfants
ça ne veut pas dire que ces enfants
contamine plus puisque pour contaminer
il faut tous et il faut cracher il faut
produire des aérosols avec du virus
et ça ça n'a pas été prouvée et combien
même ceux ci est d'éprouver faut-il
encore apporter la preuve que réellement
les enfants contamine beaucoup plus ça
n'a pas été fait il ya des études qui
vont plutôt à l'encontre où les enfants
se contamine peu plus mais eux ils ne
contamine pas davantage aux des
personnes et l'europe redoutent une
deuxième vague de l'épidémie alors les
restrictions sanitaires se multiplient
sur le continent des mesures
contraignantes dénoncer notamment à
berlin en allemagne cet après-midi
quelque vingt mille personnes ont
manifesté dans les rues de la capitale
allemande pour réclamer la levée des
restrictions
parmi les slogans remarquer bas les
masques pas de vaccination obligatoire
ou encore retour des libertés foot de
porter les masques les protestataires
ont été dispersés par la police
une course effrénée est lancée
aujourd'hui pour trouver un vaccin
l'union européenne fait déjà ses
réserves 300 millions de doses ont ainsi
été après commandé auprès de sanofi et
gsk et laboratoires français et anglais
devrait commercialiser un produit à
l'horizon 2021
les détails en images
[Musique]
où
oui
[Musique]
oh
là
[Musique]
et la russie espère de son côté entamé à
l'automne la production industrielle de
deux vaccins le ministre russe de la
santé a indiqué que l'institut gamaleya
avait terminé ses effets moscou souhaite
donc lancer des mois d'octobre une vaste
campagne de vaccination gratuite et pour
tous les citoyens
le point sur test de notre
correspondante one clairon le ministre
de la santé l'a annoncé une campagne de
vaccination massive va démarrer et ce
dès le mois d'octobre en effet les
essais cliniques du vaccin développé par
le centre gamaleya sont désormais
terminées et ce vaccin est en ce moment
même en train d'être enregistrées auprès
des autorités compétentes qui n'a donc
été choisi de vacciner la population par
groupes socioprofessionnels et donc en
premier lieu les personnels soignants et
les enseignants et un match nul
nous allons commencer par la vaccination
simultanée de groupes prioritaires
c'est-à-dire le personnel soignant et
les enseignants nous allons bien sûr
surveiller les patients vaccinés
nous prévoyons qu'il y aura une plus
large campagne de vaccination à partir
du mois d'octobre avec un nouveau
système de soins mis en place notre
vaccin développé par le laboratoire
russe vector en est en ce moment à la
phase des essais cliniques et sera lui
aussi bientôt proposer bientôt mis sur
le marché en russie espère ainsi devenir
le premier pays au monde à proposer un
vaccin fiable contre le coc vide 10
normalement le processus de
développement et de mise au point d'un
vaccin prend plusieurs années mais dans
le contexte actuel de nombreux pays dont
la russie espère donc produire et
proposer un vaccin fiable en moins de 18
mois
et pour accélérer la mise au point de ce
vaccin contre le coc u19 la technique du
challenge infectieux refait surface il
s'agit d'injecter le virus à des
volontaires sans pour tester
l'efficacité du produit
une pratique décriée la cmq chebi se
faire volontairement affecté par le cos
vie 19 pour quelques milliers d'euros
cela peut paraître fou et pourtant d
milliers de personnes sont prêtes à
franchir le pas ces patients vaccins ont
rejoint le challenge infectieux lancée
par un groupe de scientifiques dont
l'objectif est de gagner du temps sauver
des vies en accélérant la mise au point
du vaccin tout particulièrement lors de
la dernière phase des essais cliniques
habituellement la plus longue le
principe est simple
le virus est inoculé à des patients
sains jeunes et surtout volontaire avec
un dosage jugée optimale par les
scientifiques
les cobayes sont ensuite divisés en deux
groupes le premier reçoit le vaccin
thèse tandis que le second reçoit un
placebo il ne restera alors plus qu'aux
chercheurs a étudié les réponses
immunitaires du vaccin et juger de son
efficacité
si cette approche peut sembler
critiquable sur le plan éthique
ils sont pas moins de 153 scientifiques
parmi lesquels des prix nobel à la
défendre
dans une lettre ouverte adressée à
francis collins directeur des instituts
américains de santé ses partisans du
challenge un fétu affirme qu accélérer
le développement du vaccin ne serait ce
que d'un seul jour pourrait sauver
jusqu'à 3750 vie les essais sur l'homme
peuvent fournir des informations
beaucoup plus rapidement que les essais
d'efficacité conventionnel qui prennent
des mois de plus ensemble ils ont créé
la plateforme one day suhner traduisez
un jour plus tôt qui ne comptabilise pas
moins de trente-deux mille personnes
volontaires à travers 140 pays
pour appuyer leur argumentation il
rappelle que cette méthode n'est pas
nouvelle elle a notamment été utilisées
dans l'élaboration de vaccin contre la
malaria ou encore le choléra problème
cette pratique a été abandonnée depuis
les années 70 justement pour des raisons
éthiques
et bien c'est cette question l'éthique
qui divise la communauté scientifique
si l'organisation mondiale de la santé
n'y voit rien à redire
elle recommande néanmoins un encadrement
strict énumérant les critères pour
rendre acceptable
un tel challenge infectieux
parallèlement d'autres scientifiques
mettent en garde contre la méthode
jugeant les connaissances sur le sarc of
the était encore trop limités face au
risque de développer une forme grave de
la maladie infectés délibérément des
volontaires avec le strass kf2 pour
tester l'efficacité des vaccins
candidats est inutile peu informatifs et
contraire à l'éthique
l'infection peut endommager de façon
permanente le coeur les poumons le
cerveau et les reins tant chez les
jeunes que chez les personnes âgées
contrairement aux états unis ou encore
au royaume uni où le débat est encore
vif
la france reste en dehors de la
polémique même si le conseil
scientifique a fait savoir qu'il était
défavorable au challenge infectieux pour
des raisons éthiques et surtout le
scientifique
l'existence de modèles animaux
d'infection à sarko veut d'eux même
imparfait n'impose pas de recourir à
l'évaluation d'une protection chez des
jeunes volontaires en bonne santé même
si le niveau de risque est faible
on ne peut pas écarter la possibilité de
survenue d'accidents chez ces
volontaires en l'absence de
thérapeutique curatrice avérée du coc
vie de 19 dans l'hexagone priorité à
l'éthique
la question avait d'ailleurs été déjà
tranché début juillet pour que dans
cette affaire l'être humain ne soit pas
réduit au rôle de cobaye avec 4 millions
de cas de contamination et cent
cinquante trois mille morts les
etats-unis sont le pays le plus durement
touché par la pandémie
les états unis à trois mois de
l'élection présidentielle si le scrutin
a bien lieu car donald trump a suggéré
son report pour la première fois le
locataire de la maison blanche estime
qu'un vote par correspondance sera
difficile à mettre en place et sujet à
d'éventuelles fraudes
invité à préciser ses propos qu'il a
accusé la chine de tenter de
déstabiliser le processus électoral
américain
si vous allez voir une élection et nous
avons très bien organisée personne ne
veut cette date plus que moi j'aimerais
que nous puissions avancer d'accord
avancer la date mais vous n'êtes pas
préparé ce qu'ils font ils utilisent le
coc vide vous savez il utilise le virus
de la chine
la chine doit être très contente parce
qu'ils nous ont attaqués avec un virus
et maintenant ils foutent en l'air une
élection comme vous n'en verrez jamais
d'autre
enderby ce sera catastrophique pour
notre nation et vous le verrez
j'ai toujours raison sur ce genre de
choses je suppose que je dois avoir
raison sinon je ne serais pas assis la
chine soupçonnée par à washington
d'utiliser le célèbre réseau social tik
tok à des fins d'espionnage nous n'avons
pas l'intention de partir déclare la
responsable de la branche américaine
réponse à donald trump qui a annoncé sa
volonté d'interdire l'application
le réseau social chinois compte près
d'un milliard d'utilisateurs il a
souvent dieu se défendre de ses liens
avec pékin d'entreprise a toujours nié
partager des données avec les autorités
chinoises et assuré ne pas avoir
l'intention d'accepter de requête en ce
sens
l'analyse de driot drieu godefridi il
est docteur en philosophie il est tout à
fait possible que cette annonce à soi
qu'il annonce typiques de là de la
manière dont monsieur trump négociait
déjà dans le domaine des as fait à
négocier encore aujourd'hui qu'il était
à la tête de l'état américain
c'est à dire simplement un moyen de
pression pour obtenir ce qui serait dans
mon ici mon hypothèse est valide son
véritable objectif c'est-à-dire le fait
que la maison mère chinoise de tik tok
bon entreprises tic toc à d'autres
actionnaires qui quand elles seraient
totalement distinct je dirais de l'état
chinois
leleu l'autre erreur d' analyse de la
plupart des commentateurs européens
notamment et de ne pas voir que la chine
est économiquement aux abois et se
trouve aujourd'hui dans une phase de
reprise en main politique qui est la
traduction de cette très grande
faiblesse je dirais économique alors la
chine
il est impossible pour moi de dire de
quelle façon elle réagirait si cette
interdiction devenait effective mais je
ne suis pas certain réellement qu'elle
aurait les moyens politiques économiques
ou même militaire de réagir de manière
trop agressive je dirais à l'égard du
régime américain ou de ces entreprises
et or est aux états unis du côté de
portland
la mobilisation se poursuit contre les
violences policières depuis la mort de
l'afro américain john floyd asphyxié en
mai dernier à minneapolis par un
policier blanc
des manifestations ont lieu presque
chaque nuit pour tenter de maintenir
l'ordre des agents fédéraux américains
ont été envoyés sur place
une présence qui attisent les tensions
donald trump assure malgré tout qu'ils
resteront dans la ville jusqu'à ce que
la police locale se débarrasse de ce
qu'il qualifie d' anarchiste et
d'agitateurs réactions sur place s'ils
n'auraient pas dû faire du mal aux
manifestants beaucoup de gens ont été
gravement blessés je pense que c'est
vraiment une injustice sociale
les gens aiment jeter des choses mais je
ne pense pas que jeter une bouteille
d'eau équivaut à tirer sur un tas
d'autres personnes
je ne sais pas si vous voyez les
blessures ou pas mais j'ai moi même une
ecchymose à la jambe en ce moment c'est
à peu près aussi gros que de m'être fait
tirer dessus et je ne leur avaient rien
c'est j'étais juste là les policiers ne
se soucie pas vraiment sur qui il tient
ou de ce qu'ils font ce n'est vraiment
pas quelque chose qui devrait se passer
j'ai participé la moralisation juillet
environ deux ans et demi nous avons été
poussés vers l'ouest dans celle d'un
stricte et j'ai été submergé par des gaz
lacrymogènes
j'ai laissé tomber mon bouclier et
j'essayais de battre en retraite
je me suis retourné pendant quelques
minutes pour voir ce qui se passait ils
m'ont tiré dans la jambe avec un balles
en caoutchouc et pour pierre galand
professeur de civilisation américaine à
l'université paris 10 la réponse de
donald trump à ces manifestations est
une tentative pour récupérer des voix en
vue de l'élection présidentielle
je pense à une chose est sûre tous à son
élection il crée le chaos qu'ils
dénoncent par la suite et c'est une
stratégie qui n'est pas neuve
on sait très bien que l' exxon avait
utilisé une semblable
dans le passé donc il crée le problème
les manifestants principalement
pacifiques avaient des revendications
claires
l'intervention de la police fédérale que
nos vols ni les élus ni les unes ni les
gouverneurs des décombres est ni les
responsables la police locaux a pour
objectif de créer le désordre qui va
créer ces images ils seront utilisés en
campagne par la suite
top est un homme aux abois qui est fait
du cinéma
sic et ça nique pour essayer de
récupérer des voix auprès de gens qui
sont traditionnellement conservateur et
en faveur de l'or et retour en france
après une semaine de débats de
l'assemblée nationale a adopté en
deuxième lecture la nuit dernière le
projet de loi bioéthique mesure phare
l'ouverture de la procréation
médicalement assistée à toutes les
femmes le texte a été voté par 60 voix
pour 37 contre et 4 abstentions il doit
encore repasser devant senna avant que
les deux chambres ne sont tente sur une
version compromis sur twitter emmanuel
macron s'est réjoui de l'adoption du
texte par les députés le projet de loi
bioéthique vient d'être adopté en
deuxième lecture par l'assemblée
nationale
je salue l'engagement des parlementaires
des membres du gouvernement et du comité
consultatif national d'éthique
ils ont permis l'adoption d'un texte d'
équilibre dans un débat apaisé et pour
hamilton à fondateur de marianne
conseillère et chroniqueur cette loi
aurait dû être débattu à un autre moment
j'ai l'impression qu'on n'a pas assisté
tout à fait au même débat d'une part
parce qu'il ne s'agit pas d'un texte
équilibré
je crois que jamais dans 10h
parlementaires récentes un texte de loi
n'avait tenté d'introduire de telles
modifications civilisationnel
anthropologique de l'aveu même
d'ailleurs des députés de la république
en marche
je pense évidemment à la pma son père
mais on pourrait aussi citer la création
d'embryons chimères mi homme mi
nimal l'arpa qui est une gpa qui ne dit
pas son nom ou l'extension du diagnostic
préimplantatoire qui est un euphémisme à
peine voilée et tout ça au milieu de
l'été dans un mépris quand même des
parlementaires de l'opposition puisque
le des ministres ont été très très peu
présent et y lisons lorsqu'ils étaient
présents assez assez rarement un daigné
répondre aux questions des
parlementaires
donc on a quand même le sentiment d'un
débat confisqué aux français et d'un
texte qui est tout sauf eux sauf
équilibrer la prostitution des mineurs à
un fléau en expansion en france et les
protocoles pour aider ces adolescents
manque encore d'efficacité pour situer à
15 ans une jeune fille qui sont les
sorties a décidé de témoigner au micro
de rtl france c'est un reportage de
katia technique la prostitution des
mineurs en france est en progression de
ces dernières années
elle concernerait si 1000 à 10000
adolescents selon l'association agir
contre la prostitution des enfants une
mineure prostituée sur trois est âgé de
13 à 15 ans seulement
selon l'avocate spécialisée vanina mais
plein le milieu se professionnalise et
il y à aussi l'apparition de vrais
réseaux avec une structure à venir chez
le mécanisme apparemment c'est
systématiquement un recrutement via les
réseaux sociaux ou via des espèces de
rabatteuse seraient des jeunes filles
qui sont dans les lycées ou alors
qu'elles rencontrent les réseaux sociaux
les rendez vous avec les clients se
prennent sur instagram snapshot par
petites annonces et les rencontres se
font à l'hôtel ou fil du temps les
mineurs tombe sous la coupe de
proxénètes souvent issus des milieux de
la drogue
nous avons rencontré nina une
adolescente qui s'est prostituée à l'âge
de 15 ans durant une année avec son père
elle en témoigne dans un livre papa
vient me chercher aux édition de
l'observatoire nina a subi le
harcèlement à l'école puis un viol à
l'âge de 15 ans perturbé sans émotion
elle se met à fuguer et a besoin
d'argent
quand j'ai vu que je pouvais me faire
autant d'argent c'est à dire de son 40
200 euros en moins de 45 minutes je me
suis dit oui enfin l'argent a commencé à
brûler les doigts et c'est là que je
suis tombée amoureuse de l'argent li na
s'est inscrite sur un site d'escort
girls en prétendant être majeur il n'y a
pas de contrôles d'identité et c'est à
dire que c'est des rubriques vous avez
juste à poster une photo de votre corps
à mettre vos mensurations et votre
numéro
moi je crois que la première fois je me
suis connecté j'ai eu 80 90 appels nina
tombe sous la coupe de son petit ami
proxénète et devient accro à la cocaïne
elle vit très mal la situation le fait
que chaque homme me détruise comme ça un
petit peu que je me tue à petit feu en
fait je vivais ça et puis je me suis
rendu compte que je pouvais pas avoir
une vie dans sa je me disais mais nina
tu vas finir à 19 ans à la mort vu
complètement shooté mais au bout d'un an
de déchéance
un soir elle a le déclic j'ai appelé mes
parents ils étaient 3 2 3 heures du
matin j'étais complètement drogué et je
leur ai dit j'ai besoin de votre aide je
suis désolé pardon pardon de tout ce que
je vous ai fait pardon d'une balle que
j'ai plus vous infligez et je veux me
battre et je veux m'en sortir et et mon
papa a appelé la gendarmerie est en fait
c'est la police qui est venue nous
chercher
mis à part le soutien des associations
la famille de nina très éprouvés n'a
reçu aucune aide des parents des proches
ne peuvent pas obliger effectivement un
mineur à être s'agit pas de le mettre
dans un hôpital spécialisé mais de
suivre obligatoirement ou d'avoir une
obligation de soins rien est adapté
effectivement spécifiquement pour les
mineurs
en quand on est un interlocuteur que ce
soit police parquet justice services
sociaux il ya ce sentiment de
culpabilité
donc on est déjà effectivement dans le
stress d'avoir sa gamine qui fait des
choses
11 16 ou et kid réellement en danger
et là on a pu effectivement pas
l'accompagnement rien du tout une
enquête sur la prostitution des mineurs
en france datant d'octobre 2010 9 a bien
confirmé ces manquements peu de prise en
charge par l'aide sociale à l'enfance
peu d' enquête de police ouverte
pas d'action et peu de condamnations
afin de lutter contre ce fléau un
dispositif expérimental a été signé en
juillet en seine saint denis un début de
réponse
mais il reste des dizaines de
départements à couvrir une france 1 - de
cette marche blanche qui était organisée
aujourd'hui à sarcelles dans le
val-d'oise pour rendre hommage à thomas
le jeune homme de 23 ans a trouvé la
mort dans la nuit du 10 au 11 juin après
avoir reçu huit coups de couteau au mois
de mai
thomas passé la soirée chez un ami qui
était présent un homme multi récidiviste
tout juste sortie de prison sont de
canon suivi judiciaire une décision
justice que ne comprend pas la famille
de la victime
si le rassemblement national s'est
indigné de ne voir aucun volet
médiatique sur cet aspect sur cette
affaire comparativement aux meurtres
d'adama traoré la cousine de la victime
a demandé à ce qu'aucune appropriation
politique ne soit fait et c'est la fin
de ce journal prochain point sur l'actu
dans une trentaine de minutes à tout à
l'heure
[Musique]
pourquoi vous maintenez le traitement à
base d'hydroquinone azithromycine malgré
la polémique mondiale sur l'efficacité
de cette combinaison général
nous avions déjà commencé à utiliser le
protocole avec les boutiques préoccupe
bien avant que le match ne commence son
essai par sénégal la chloroquine de
manière à les utiliser pendant des
décennies et des décennies ça pourrait
faire sourire les sénégalais quand
j'entends des dinosaures il n'y a pas de
signes qui m'est rendu
voilà ce que j'ai trouvé
[Musique]